are we there yet this beach it's  beautiful  my swimsuit is hurting they do look  small come on let's play hide and seek  have you seen my children mom i'm right  here  he was six years old this morning  oh no mom i'm scared  there's something wrong with this beach  we were chosen for a reason  what's happening i don't know i can't  think  old only in theaters this summer are we  there yet  this beach it's beautiful my swimsuit is  hurting  they do look small come on let's play  hide and seek  have you seen my children mom i'm right  here  he was six years old this morning  oh no mom i'm scared  there's something wrong with this beach  we were chosen for a reason  what's happening i don't know i can't  think  owned only in theaters this summer